since you mentioned joe rogan in that
little example uh
what happened to you in terms of bicep
too
i want to kind of speak um
at a high level about a particular thing
i observed so i was a fan of joe rogan
uh since he started the podcast just
listening to the podcast i'm a huge fan
of podcasts in general yeah and
it also coincided with my entry into
grad school and this whole journey of
academia so grad school getting my phd
and going to mit and then google and
then just looking at this whole world of
research
what i
really loved about
how joe rogan approaches the world
is that he celebrates others
like he promotes them he gets like
genuinely and i now know this from just
being a friend privately he genuinely
gets excited
by the success of others
and
the contrast of that
to how
folks in academia often behave was
always really disappointing to me
because the natural just on a basic
human level
there is
an excitement but the nature of that
excitement is more like
i'm happy for my friend
but i'm really jealous and i want to
even i'll do them i want to celebrate
them but i want to do even better so
even that's even for friends yeah so
there's not a genuine pure excitement
for others and then uh to couple that
with just the you now as a as a host of
a popular podcast know this feeling
which is like there's not even a
willingness to celebrate publicly
the awesomeness of others
people in academia
are often best equipped
technically in terms of language to
celebrate others they understand the
beauty
like the
the full richness of why the the cool
idea is as cool as it is and they're in
the best position to celebrate it and
yet there's a feeling that if i
celebrate
others they might end up on the cover of
nature whatever and not me
it's they turn it into a zero-sum game
what i the reason why
i think uh rogan has been inspiration to
me and many others is that it doesn't
have to be that yeah and forget money
and all those kinds of things that
i think there's a narrative told
that
uh academics are this way
because there's a limited amount of
money and so they're fighting for this i
don't
think
that's the reason it's happening this
way i think uh i think you you can have
a limited amount of money the battle for
money
happens in the space of proposal there's
networking there's private stuff
public celebration of others and all and
just actually just how you feel in the
privacy of your own heart
is not have to do anything with money it
has to
do with you having a big ego not
humbling yourself to the beauty of the
journey that we are all on and there's
folks like joe rogan who in the comedian
circles is also rare but he inspired all
these other comedians to realize you
know what it's great to celebrate each
other we're promoting each other and
therefore the pie grows yeah because
everybody else gets excited about this
whole thing and the pie grows right now
the scientists by fighting like by not
celebrating each other and not growing
the pie and now
because of that sort of science becomes
less and less positive flywheel and
exactly no and i want to point out two
things one is that i remember you went
on joe's show maybe a couple years ago
and um and then he gave you a watch
and gave you like a rolex right yeah and
i tweeted to you and i think omega omega
sorry okay fine uh the watch that went
to the to the moon which we will get to
in a bit um i don't think he could give
you what i gave you though by the way um
and we'll get to what that final gift
package is for you and by the way i also
wanted to mention because when you said
joe i would not be upset and you should
definitely go on joe rogan and i we had
this conversation with him yeah
because i was like when i was uh
uh so moving to austin
and had a conversation like don't you
think it's weird like if we have the
same guests the same time or whatever
he's like
[ __ ] that
i want you to be more successful than me
i want he he truly wants everybody like
especially people close to him to be
more successful like there's not even a
thought like but you know why he does
and this is what i tweeted to you and
one of the few things i think you have
retweeted that i sent you i said someday
you're going to give that to somebody
and today i wanted that to be me no no
joe's omega no but but the point is he
sees in you that same
you know grandiosity that same genuine
spirit graciousness and i think that's
true i mean you do do something very
rare i don't turn this into too much of
a love fest but i do want to say even
back to andrew you know who i've almost
been hate geographic about you know just
treating him like a saint he said to me
the same thing in a moment of peak i
said like
god damn it like i have to train these
guys and women that work for me
so that they can be better than me so
that they can go out and compete with me
for the same limited amount of funding
from the f-ing nsl you know
that wasn't his that wasn't who he was
um that was just an expression like i'm
doing something which is fundamentally
but you know what um
when you have kids hopefully you know
please god you will someday because i
think and i hope we can get to talk
about that later but
part of investment and part of doing
something with when you have a kid like
you can get married
you can marry someone because she's rich
or he's rich you can marry someone
because they're good looking or he's
good look
you can marry for all these different
reasons that are ultimately selfish
there's no way you can have a kid and be
selfish nobody says like oh you know
what i really want this thing that's
three feet tall that doesn't speak
english it craps on my floor that wakes
me up all hours of the night that
interferes my love life nobody says that
because it doesn't benefit you for
months and months a friend of mine who
actually does the videos for me that
does a lot of my solo videos he's having
his first kid he's like what do i do
because it always gets stupid i'll catch
up on sleep now like yeah i'm gonna
store sleep in my sleep bank like i
don't think hubermann and you talked
about that right you can't do that
that's stupid what you can do give the
kid a bath feed the baby let the mother
relax like in other words do the things
and and this really relates back to
aristotle once aristotle said why do
parents love kids more than kids love
parents as much as you love your dad and
your mom
they still love you more
and because you love that which you
sacrifice for here's a proof
um i know a lot of families that have
kids with special needs some some with
severe
my one of my uncles uh from the keating
side had uh severe what they called
mental retardation now it's probably has
a different name
that out of the nine other brothers and
sisters he was their favorite
because they had to sacrifice so much
for him
and i think of that you know in the
small case like joe is kind of mentoring
you or whatever you're going to mentor
someone you love that which you
sacrifice for sacrifice is reduction of
entropy it's storing and investing and
you want to protect that
you